on en a déjà parlé dans le premier
épisode de cette série l'ia est en train
d'atteindre des facultés surhumaines
pour certaines tâches médicales
notamment en termes de diagnostic
médical
et là je sens les médecins parmi vous
froncer des sourcils descendre dans la
partie commentaire est prêt à me
reprocher ma condescendance
c'est un réflexe n'est d'ailleurs pas
spécifique à la médecine même les
chercheurs anglais ont tendance à
surestimer leurs facultés vis-à-vis de
leurs machines
les experts en il estime ainsi que le
métier de chercheur en ir sera le
dernier remplacé et le sera bien après
le moment où l'ia atteindra des facultés
surhumaines
alors que par définition liée à deux
niveaux humains est définie comme celle
surpassant tout humain dans toute tâche
bref quelle que soit notre métier on a
tendance à se voir plus beau et plus
irremplaçable que l'on ne l'est alors
qu'à bien y réfléchir il ya souvent de
nombreuses parties de nos jobs où
l'humain n'excelle pas particulièrement
et avant d'en arriver à un stade où la
médecine sera largement automatisés pour
le bien des patients
il pourra bien être dès à présent
souhaitable de déléguer certaines tâches
à la machine tient prix moto qui est
médecin tu en penses quoi
salut les mais qu'est ce que j'en pense
et 20 gens pensent que le patient prime
et si en termes de diagnostic et larry
statistiquement à faire mieux que
l'humain alors l'ia peut-être utile et
il faudra utiliser car sinon c'est une
perte de chance pour le patient on peut
illustrer cela avec trois exemples ainsi
début 2010 est une collaboration
d'informaticiens et de médecins de
l'université de stanford a réussi à
construire une ia qui à partir de
photographies d'irrégularités au niveau
de la peau diagnostic les cancers de la
peau avec plus de justesse que des
dermatologues
on va simplifier le problème en trois
grandes situation soit la lésion est
bénigne il va falloir la prendre en
charge
c'est pas trop ce qui va nous intéresser
ici soit c'est un cancer de la peau très
fréquent mais pas très agressif et peu
mortelle qu'on appelle le baso
cellulaire soit c'est un des autres
types de cancers de la peau plus rares
mais pour le coup plus agressifs et plus
mortelle voire très agressif et très
mortels on pense en priorité aux
mélanomes le traitement principal des
cancers de la peau c'est la chirurgie il
faut enlever la lésion mais pas que il
faut également enlevé une zone de
sécurité autour de la lésion qu'on
appelle une marge et cette marge
elle va dépendre du type et de
l'agressivité du cancer pour les
basocellulaire il faut prendre entre 5
mm et un centimètre de marche de plus
autour de la lésion pour les autres
types de cancer c'est entre 1 et 3 cm de
marge en plus autour de la lésion c'est
à dire que si vous avez une lésion de
5 mm de mauvais pronostic le trou qui va
être fait mesure 6,5 cm de diamètre
c'est ça si j'ai eu 5 cm de diamètre sur
le doubs l'abdomen ça pose pas trop de
soucis mais à d'autres endroits comme le
crâne ou le visage c'est beaucoup plus
complexe à reconstruire
donc ce qu'on aime bien c'est de faire
des diagnostics précoces 1 s'est vite
les maladies trop étendu est trop
avancée de ses élites les séquelles trop
importante
ça c'est un point de vue purement
médical que ce soit pour le patient ou
techniquement mais si vous rajoutez en
plus le volet économique à la faire il
est évident qu'un cancer dépisté tôt
génère moins de dépenses pour la
collectivité
donc c'est un intérêt majeur deuxième
exemple au milieu de l'année 2010 est
une autre équipe de cinq ford est
parvenu à concevoir une autre ia capable
de mieux détecter les arythmies
cardiaques que des cardiologues à partir
d'électro carte de grave pour l'électro
cardiogramme c'est un peu le même
problème c'est un examen que tous les
médecins apprennent à lire mais c'est
très rigoureux et il ya énormément de
subtilité et beaucoup de pièges
ça permet par exemple de faire des
diagnostics d'infarctus ça c'est quand
une artère du coeur se bouche et donc le
coeur n'est plus alimentée en sang ni en
oxygène ce qui peut rapidement conduire
à la mort suivies de décès mais ça
permet également des diagnostics plus
subtile par exemple ce qu'on appelle des
troupes de conduction sont des
pathologies qui altèrent la conduction
du message électrique responsable de la
contraction du coeur
et croyez moi quand je vous dis que
c'est un message qui nécessite une
séquence très précise il est assez
facile pour un humain de passer à côté
de ces pathologies cas il s'agit point
subtil de l'analyse comme des temps de
pause un petit peu trop long ou des
signes d'excitation électrique un petit
peu précoce
ces pathologies elles sont pourvoyeuses
de mort subite par arrêt cardiaque
brutal
ça serait donc pas mal de les repérer en
amont et pour le coup il serait plutôt
facile pour unia d'apprendre à les
repérer du fait du volume d'exemple
disponibles et de la systématisation de
l'analyse par l'ia est donc l'appareil
on comprend l'intérêt de diagnostic et
efficacement et précocément ces
problèmes tant pour le patient pour lui
éviter des complications et des
séquelles comme des paralysies des
insuffisances cardiaques ou des décès
que pour la communauté d'un point de vue
économique moins de problèmes
ça veut dire moins de soins mon
traitement moins de complications moins
de dépendance et des gens en meilleure
santé et donc moins de dépenses au
niveau individuel
mais également collectif enfin fin 2017
une troisième équipe de stanford a cette
fois surpassé les performances des
radiologues dans la détection de
pathologies pulmonaires à partir de
radiographie standards du thorax des
patients la finalité est encore une fois
la même améliorer le diagnostic s'est
amélioré la prise en charge les diminuer
les complications et les séquelles
la problématique avec la radio thorax
elle est assez proche de la
problématique de le cg à savoir que
l'interprétation de l'examen est
complexe et soumis à plein de pièges
donc on peut se tromper à la différence
que le cg est un examen qui est en
général précis avec des pièges parfois
très subtil alors que l'arrêt de thorax
et un examen de débrouillage parfois
grossier même s'il ya des subtilités et
donc beaucoup plus permissif aux erreurs
la radio thorax c'est quelque chose de
compliqué et bien entendu il s'agit là
de trois succès parmi d'autres il ya
probablement bien d'autres tâches que
les ja sauront mieux résoudre que les
experts humain cependant il faut faire
attention à ne pas déployer les ja dans
des cas où les diagnostics des ia ne
sont pas clairement supérieure aux
experts humains ou amidon clé est-ce que
tu saurait caractériser les cas où les
ja ont des chances de surpasser les
médecins c'est pas évident à dire
notamment sachant la vitesse des progrès
en ira mais les tâches dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui on tout quelques
caractéristiques communes qui font que
leur succès pouvait être raisonnablement
attendues en particulier pour toutes ces
tâches on dispose de beaucoup de données
étiquetés autrement dit on dispose d'un
grand nombre de photos d'irrégularités
de la peau et on sait pour beaucoup de
ces photos si les patients ont contracté
un cancer de la peau ou non or lorsqu'on
le nathan de données étiqueté on peut
faire de l'apprentissage d'y superviser
c'est l'apprentissage dont on a parlé
dans l'épisode 8 et en gros aujourd'hui
quand il s'agit d'apprentissage
superviser surtout sur des images dès
qu'on a suffisamment de données on peut
être raisonnablement confiant qu'une ia
surpassera l'humain ouais sauf que
l'examen médical et la démarche
diagnostique c'est pas que regarder une
radio un ecg une lésion cutanée il ya
aussi une partie d'interrogatoire
clinique avec recherches d'antécédents
par exemple ou recherche de signes
cliniques particulier et le médecin il
doit aussi questionné établir une
relation de confiance rassure et
accompagner et c est ça alésia qui ne
font que de la pointe et a supervisé
elles ne savent pas faire en fait il
semble que pour devenir bien plus utile
on sentait les ja compte de voix
grandement
progresser elles devront notamment
réussir à utiliser des notions de bon
sens ou une connaissance globale de
l'anatomie humaine afin d'effectuer des
diagnostics de maladies dont elle ne
dispose que de peu de données ce
problème de raisonnement en présence de
peu de données pertinentes est en fait
plus généralement connu sous le nom de
one shot learning et il s'agit de l'un
des grands défis de la recherche
actuelle en intelligence artificielle
que l'on semble encore très loin d'avoir
résolu de façon plus générale il faut
réussir à se rendre compte que parmi
l'ensemble des tâches utiles pour
soigner optimalement impatients si
certaines sont mieux résolus par des ja
aujourd'hui la plupart leur sont assez
inaccessible et qui plus est comme on
parle de santé unia qui marchent souvent
ne suffit pas même si elle fonctionne
bien 99% du temps si elle risque de
complètement dysfonctionné pendant le 1%
restant alors un pour cent des patients
à risque alors la mort or en ia il est
souvent relativement aisé de concevoir
une ia avec un taux de réussite de 80%
mais il peut être extrêmement difficile
de lui faire atteindre un taux de
réussite de 99 99% n'approche qui semble
plus prometteuse pourrait alors être des
délia à mieux cerner l'étendue de son
ignorance de sorte qu'elles sachent
identifier les cas où le patient est
clairement malades ceux où il est
clairement sein mais aussi les cas où
l'irs n'a pas suffisamment d'expertisé
pour trancher et doit alors faire appel
un médecin autrement dit comme tout
humain il y as doit prendre conscience
de l'étendue de son ignorance
cependant même si unies à un taux de
réussite de 99 99%
il restera toujours des cas ou alors à
tort et donc se trompera et où elle
causera des morts et il se posera donc
la question de la responsabilité quand
il ya une erreur médicale
et je parle pas d'aléa thérapeutique un
mais bien d'erreurs il y à au moins un
responsable le médecin est responsable
de ses actes mais si on délègue à une
machine même très performante qui ne
fait une erreur que dans un cas sur un
million
qui est responsable en cas d'erreur le
médecin ou la structure qui utilisent la
machine le constructeur les programmeurs
les législateurs qui autorise
l'utilisation de la machine
c'est le même problématique avec les
voitures autonomes ça fera probablement
mieux que l'humain mais s'il ya une
faute qui en prend la responsabilité
sont des questions qui doivent se poser
en amont de l'utilisation
bref l'application de l'ia en santé
comme partout ailleurs soulève de
nombreuses questions et
inédite dans l'histoire de l'humanité il
ne va sans doute pas être facile de
débattre de manière calme et raisonnée
d'autant que dans le futur il ya
pourrait avoir bien d'autres
applications encore en santé de
nombreuses il cherche ainsi à anticiper
les épidémies à l'aide de vos activités
sur le web pour mieux se préparer à les
combattre
d'autres y recherchent aussi à
contribuer à l'organisation des hôpitaux
en gérant par exemple planning du
personnel et la répartition des lits et
des places et à plus long terme les yeux
pour est effectué un travail de veille
pour suggérer aux médecins les derniers
traitements en date voir directement
participé à la conception de nouveaux
médicaments
enfin sur le très long terme elle
pourrait collecter toutes sortes de
données génomiques et physiologiques par
exemple à l'aide de montres connecter
pour toujours mieux diagnostiquer vos
potentiels pathologie et ceux à faible
coût et de manière peu intrusive et
ainsi vous proposer des traitements très
personnalisés mais pour en arriver là il
va falloir que à l'instar des études de
standford informaticien et médecins
travaillent main dans la main avec
l'objectif de tout faire pour le bien
des patients elle j'espère que vous avez
aimé cette vidéo un grand merci à
françois de la chaîne primum de nos
séries sans qui cette vidéo aurait été
très très très compliqué à écrire et
c'était vraiment génial pour moi d'avoir
un médecin avec qui travailler sur ce
genre de questions notamment mieux
comprendre quelles sont les difficultés
les enjeux des médecins voient je pense
vraiment que pour faire des progrès des
applications de l'innocenter il va
falloir absolument qui est une
collaboration ce genre de collaboration
du caire entre des gens qui connaissent
très bien la médecine et des gens qui
connaissent très bien
l'intelligence artificielle quand on y
réfléchit c'est quand même une chance
inouïe que l'on a sur youtube d'avoir
toutes ces expertises diverses et
variées et qui ont pu savoir des
collaborations interdisciplinaires et
merci françois pour sa participation et
je recommande vivement sa chaîne
notamment par exemple ces vidéos sur le
cancer ou sur les maladies vaccinale
pour se rendre de comptes sont des
maladies qui sont vraiment très très
grave
du coup faut vraiment utiliser des
technologies très avancées comme les
vaccins ou la chimiothérapie qui peuvent
avoir certains défauts notamment dans le
cas des cheminots thérapie mais c'est
vraiment pour lutter contre un mal qui
est vraiment horrible tout cas je
regrette vivement les vidéos de primum
l'anr fois me faisait parler du problème
des assurances notamment dans une époque
de big data et intelligence artificielle
où toutes sortes de données sont
collectées qui vous concerne et qui du
coup peuvent affecter les prix des
assurances que vous payez je vais
partager avec vous un peu mon inquiétude
vis-à-vis de certaines vidéos que j'ai
vu tant confessons l'étendue d'eau au
menu notamment sur les considérations
juridiques vis-à-vis de ces assurances
errishi 120 à laisser un commentaire
absolument géniale qui parle des
réglementations qu'en fait qui existe
dans le cas en tout cas d assurance
santé
comment ce qui est intéressant de voir
s'il ya pas mal de mesures qui ont été
prises assez récemment notamment depuis
une dizaine d'années apparemment après
le commentaire de richy puis notamment
la cnil la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés est très
active sur ce sujet là donc en france en
fait ça se passe relativement bien ou
assez concernés par ce genre de craintes
malheureusement ce n'est pas forcément
le cas à l'étranger aux frais techniques
et à ma connaissance en tout cas c'est
le sentiment que j'ai peut-être que je
me trompe mais j'ai pas l'impression de
tromper
en france on a vraiment la chance
d'avoir ce cas assez parti tu es d'avec
nick est très puissante et très
influente c'est beaucoup moins le cas à
l'étranger
enfin le pire étant notamment aux états
unis où les prix des assurances de santé
sont incroyablement personnalisés et
c'est pour ça que surtout aux états unis
les informations de santé sur le dossier
médicaux ont vraiment une valeur énorme
écrit notamment le problème de la
protection des données privées aux états
unis est vraiment très très
problématique
alors c'est pas un hasard si la
réglementation hergé [ __ ] sur la
protection des données privées est une
réglementation de l'union européenne epa
des états-unis
ceci dit enrichissant 20 ajoute que ces
réglementations sont particulièrement
contraignante dans le domaine de
l'assurance santé
mais qu'en est il des autres assurances
habitation ou voiture voilà la question
ouverte je sais pas s'il y en a qui
connaissent mais je pense que ça sera
pas mal de réfléchir un peu à ces
différentes problématiques
je joue à 9,64 ajoute que finalement les
impôts sont une forme d'assurance et en
fait c'est vraiment le cas si vous y
réfléchissez
non seulement ça participe à la
destruction de richesse mais c'est aussi
une forme de avoir accès à des choses
qui vont nous permettre d'avoir une
sécurité par rapport à des cas
particulièrement catastrophique par
exemple si un tsunami peut avoir des
aides souvent gouvernementales et du
coup ça marche
indirectement comme une certaine forme
d'assurance une certaine forme d' aide
aux personnes qui subissent des
accidents dramatiques
d'une façon plus générale on peut voir
les impôts comme eto'o ne souffre aucune
forme de dons caritatifs donne en fait
pour une institution qui va ensuite
essayer d'aider le plus grand nombre de
manière plus efficace possible
bien sûr les institutions publiques ne
sont pas forcément très optimale et il
ya pas mal de gâchis il reste néanmoins
qu'il s'agit d'une très bonne façon
d'aider un maximum de personnes
peut-être l'une des manières les plus
efficaces en fait de venir en aide au
plus grand nombre
c'est simplement de payer des impôts et
du coup je trouve ça souvent assez
dommage que la notion de payer les
impôts est souvent associé à quelque
chose de mal on aime se plaindre de
payer les impôts alors que finalement ça
revient à se plaindre de devoir être un
petit peu altruiste donc se plaindre de
payer des impôts finalement c'est un
acte profondément anti altruiste dans le
truck profondément égoïste au final est
bien sûr le problème souvent c'est qu'on
associe un pot avec gouvernement et on
est assez hooligans par rapport au
gouvernement du coup on n'a pas envie de
donner nos impôts lorsque le mec qui est
au pouvoir est quelqu'un que l'on aime
pas mais j'ai envie de dire que cette
personne qui est au pouvoir n'est pas
celle qui utilise plus cet argent public
et il ya une institution publique qui
ont vraiment besoin de cet argent pour
essayer d'aider aussi bien que possible
le plus grand nombre
doctorat perron notamment souligner que
ce système notamment via la sécurité
sociale est finalement vraiment une un
système d'assurance non personnalisée
qui va chercher vraiment à aider
notamment les personnes qui ont le plus
besoin et en cela c'est quand même
quelque chose de très perturbée que
c'est finalement ça répond vraiment à
cette notion de décide de venir en aide
aux personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
si je vais quand même mettre un bémol à
cela
en tant que théoricien déjà il ya
toujours quelque chose auquel le régime
bien réfléchir c'est la notion d
incentives quels sont les incentives y
sont donnés un système centralisé par un
gouvernement bien une sécurité sociale
par l'opposition un système très
libérale où on aurait des assurances
privées
ce qui est intéressant dans le cas pu
laisser que le privé y va quand même
cherché à donner des incentives aux gens
d'essayer de se comporter de manière à
réduire leurs coûts individuels qui
revient aussi et du coup à diminuer le
coût de l'assurance pour la société donc
typiquement si on sait que les prix des
assurances ont augmenté si on fume des
cigarettes ça donne un initiative
individuelle à moins fumer ce qui va
ensuite réduire les coûts de la prise en
charge du cancer possible potentiel du
poumon et du coup diminuer le coût que
devra payer toute la société
finalement ce genre d'initiative est
finalement socialement pas mal même s'il
a pour conséquence que du coup la
personne qui fume parce qu'elle est dans
un environnement qui poussent les fumées
et ses défilés c'est difficile d'arrêter
de fumer va devoir payer un prix
d'assurance qui est plus élevé qu'il ne
le serait si tout le système était
entièrement centralisée par une sécurité
sociale et de l'autre côté il ya aussi
pas mal d'initiatives du côté des
assureurs de diminuer autant que
possible les coupes de gestion notamment
s'il ya des concurrences entre
différentes assurances et ça
malheureusement ces initiatives qui
disparaît un petit peu dans le cadre de
la sécurité sociale où on va du coup
beaucoup moins cherché à avoir un
système efficace fluide qui consomment
au petit peu de ressources que possible
bref il s'est pas tout blanc ou tout
noir irak il ya quand même des avantages
à ce que les systèmes assurant soit pas
entièrement public tout comme il ya des
problèmes avec ce qu'elle soit
entièrement public donc je pense que sur
ce genre de questions pour essayer faire
attention à ne pas être trop le guen est
vraiment essayé de peser le pour et le
contre et sans doute qu'un pont
compromis et finalement quelque chose
d'assez est souhaitable un système
partiellement libéral mais quand même
pas mal régulé en tout cas si on se
donne pour objectif de prendre en charge
aussi bien que possible un maximum de
personnes qui en ont le plus besoin
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
la prochaine fois on va continuer à
avoir un peu les applications de l'ia
qui ont des conséquences sociales assez
importantes notamment on parlera des
relations entre l'île
l'environnement si vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la l'ikea le commentaire
de partage et pensez à vous abonner pour
une beuverie futur épisode monsieur
oliver pardo et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois si vous devez
retenir qu'une seule chose de cet
épisode c'est ce que je vais dire
maintenant le cancer n'est pas synonyme
de décès avant c'était le cas oui au
début du 20e siècle c'était le cas au
milieu du xxème siècle c'était encore le
cas mais aujourd'hui c'est absolument
plus le cas avec l'intelligence
artificielle le contact entre l'expert
et les personnes du secteur est vital
que ce soit au point de vue pragmatique
au point de vue théorique il ya quelques
années et emmanuel quand des
mathématiciens en poste à stanford
l'un des experts dans certains domaines
intelligence artificielle nous parler de
sa collaboration suivie avec des
médecins dans un hôpital pour mettre au
point de nouvelles techniques d'analysé
du signal qui permettent de réduire d'un
facteur 8 le temps qu'il nous faut pour
passer dans un scanner un exemple de
collaboration passionnante ouvre de
nouvelles voies et de nouveaux rêves
dans le dialogue entre la mathématique
et les autres s'y perd